All right, so by now you should
have a fairly decent sized list
of apps that you might be
interested in pursuing.
See if you can whittle that down
to about three that you would be
super excited to work on.
And, once you've done that, it's
time to get feedback on these ideas.
One of the most important parts of iOS
app development is to get feedback
early and often.
So let's do that.
Go ahead and
post your three app ideas to the forum
along with descriptions on
what you want them to do.
While you're there, respond to
two of your classmates posts and
give them feedback.
And then, while you're waiting for
feedback, share your app ideas
with your friends and family.
What do they think?
Now go forth.
Give feedback.
I mean it.
Shoo.
Get out of here.
Get out of class.
Go talk to people.
See what they think.
It'll really help you decide what
you want to pursue in the end.